her
is now adding country artist to her
resume after rocking the cmt stage with
chris stapleton oh my gosh it feels
crazy
on wednesday night the triple threat
performed alongside the country artist
at the cmt
music awards singing her song hold on
not only did their performance blow away
the audience but even hosts kane brown
and kelsey ballerini
admitted they had been waiting for this
moment all night this collaboration we
got to watch dress rehearsal i'm
fangirling right now
it's all happening uh it's once in a
lifetime
it's incredible
[Music]
e.t spoke with her ahead of her
performance at the ceremony and dished
on how the performance came together
and teased more country collabs how did
this collaboration come to be
you know i'm a huge chris stapleton fan
and i think uh
yeah we've been talking about it for
such a long time so it was like
a phone call like hey want to perform at
the country music television you know
awards with me and he was like yeah of
course i would love to and he said
that his daughter was a really big fan
so i was like oh my gosh we got to do
this
it's a pinch me moment i do love this
fusion though of country music and the r
b
genre we've seen jasmine sullivan
perform with eric church now we've got
you with chris stapleton what do you
make of it
honestly you know both of the the things
that connect those two genres are the
blues and
soul music and gospel music so i think
we all have a common
ground here you know the roots are the
same you know and it's
just different translations of stories
honest stories and yes
that's what we're here to do you know
music unites people so i think that's
what we're here
so would it be safe to say that this
might be
not be the last time that we see you in
the country music scene
absolutely not i have some
collaborations coming that you don't
even know about yet that i can't give
away but
yeah are those people here by any chance
they might be here yes i swear they
might be here listen there's only about
30 artists here because of cobia so i
can do a process of elimination is it a
female artist male artist
what can you share i can't i can't can't
share anything with you yet but it's
[Music]
coming